un salon professionnel bien particulier
réservé aux spécialistes de la sécurité
militaire et de la police vient de
s'achever à paris
ces visiteurs étaient principalement
donc des professionnels mais aussi il
faut lire certains particuliers qui ont
toutes les raisons d'avoir envie de se
sentir bien protégés reportage d' hervé
brusini et philipp etter s'était claire
des espions des amateurs de
refroidissement brutal était à mes
trousses
il fallait au plus vite consulté des
spécialistes gillet vip de ce type là
couiza beaupré 3000 points
hors taxes
oui ça fait partie des modèles les moins
chers qui ont sauf quand même une
protection aux 9 mm parabellum et en 357
magnum
même si on chie sentir deuxième si on me
tire dessus à bout touchant
parfait deuxième étape la voiture
blindée bien sûr peut-être une rolls
vitres de cinq centimètres d'épaisseur g
automatique de gaz lacrymogènes au fait
combien pour ce petit bijou faut compter
un million et demi pour taxes
et les taxes et combien le dessus
hans 33%
ban blindés perforation assurée pistolet
entièrement démontable l'équipement de
base en somme un peu trop violent quand
même pour moi à moins que je ne confie
l'exécution des basses oeuvres à ce
robot avec caméras micros fusil à visée
laser au fait sans prix entre 300 et 600
mille francs
toutes taxes comprises
taxes bonjour monsieur je
voilà je voudrais quelque fois
enregistrez des gens des conversations
vous avez quoi comme matériel
vous pouvez un
balance
apache été
le premier convoi
et c'est mérité car ça va ils s'arrêtent
d'accord et la ceinture là chacun sa
similaire le micro et dans le centre
et ça marche bien de ça marche bien et
c'est légal
pas folle la guêpe je ne serai pas pris
à mon propre piège grâce à cet engin
il est capable de repérer n'importe où
n'importe quel micro 150 mille francs
hors taxes nature y est
et vous ce mini ce pardon vous pensez
faire quelques emplettes faire un choix
ici ou pas
s'il représentait
beaucoup d'entreprises au ministère de
l'intérieur et est déjà client c'est pas
moi qui ai dit monsieur sur une pierre
directeur logistique de la police
régionale
dernière trouvaille ni vu ni connu cette
bombe rang transparent toutes les
enveloppes ça je le réserve aux
courriers de ma femme mais c'est une
toute autre histoire